مجله العلميه مجله دوريه لها وزنها يعني
وثقلها ومن كم يوم نزلت فيها نتائج دراسه
عامله صدى كبير الدراسه عنوانها عباره عن
سؤال وبيقول هل توقف لب الارض الداخلي عن
دورانو وفي التفاصيل كانوا بيقولوا
العلماء اللي شغالين على الدراسه في جامعه
بكين انه رصد انه اللب الداخلي لكوكب
الارض واللي معروف ان هو بيدور توقف عن
الدوران العقد الماضي وبس كده لا هو الان
في مرحله تعادل انعكاس الدوران وبتوقع انه
يرجع يبدا بالدوران لكن بالاتجاه المعاكس
وجاي العلماء في الدراسه انا الموضوع راح
يكون له اثار على كوكب الارض ولكن ما
بتوصل لدرجه الخطوره الشديده الدراسه
بتتوقع انه الدوران العكسي هيبدا في 20 40
والعلماء من زمان كانوا توصلوا لانه
بالارض بيدور بسرعه اكبر من قشرتها الخبر
هذا طبعا انتشر من هنا وهمم والدنيا كلها
طبعا مملت اسئله واستفسارات وكلام عن انه
ايش
كثير او تغيير اللي هيحجزوا هذا الامر على
الكوكب والبشريه ونسرحت ابعد من كده كمان
وبدات تتكلم انه هذه النتائج معناها انه
لا نهايه العالم اقتربت والناس بتقول انه
لا انعكاس الدوران يعني الشمس هتشرق من
الغرب وهذه عاد من علامات يوم القيامه
عشان نفهم الموضوع لازم نتكلم معه نقطه
فخلونا نسال ضيفنا اللي بينضم الينا من
القاهره استاذ الجيولوجيا دكتور عباس شرقي
اهلا فيك معنا الدكتور عباس همم هل نقدر
نقول انه نحن مقبلين على يعني كارثه
ونهايه العالم والكلام هذا كله
لا اولا تحياتي لحضرتك ولكل الساده
للمشاهدين
الحقيقه يعني هذا البحث جاء ببعض
المعلومات عن ااا مركز الكره الارضيه اللي
بنقول عليه لب الكره الارضيه ده اللوجو
الكره الارضيه عباره عن كره حديديه مكونه
من حديد ونيكل وبالتالي هي وزنها يعني
كبير بالنسبه لباقي صخور القشره الارضيه
هذه الكره بتدور مع الارض ونفس الاتجاه
وحاول نفس محور الكره الارضيه هذه الكتله
الحديديه
بتنمو مع الوقت بتزيد وهي المسؤوله عن
الجاذبيه في الكره الارضيه ايوه هي
المسؤوله عن المجال المغناطيسي اللي موجود
في الكره الارضيه واللي بيحمي ال- الكره
الارضيه وبما انه بيزيد في الحجم لان مع
مرور الوقت بيحصل تبريد للكره الارضيه
وبتتكون بلورات حديديه
بتنجذب لهذه الكتله لان هذه الكتله محاطه
همم منطقه كلها صهير يعني سوائل فهي كتله
حديديه صلبه والحقيقه هنا صلبه في وسط
حراره اكثر من 7,000 درجه مئويه وهنا يجيء
السؤال كيف لحراره 7,000 درجه مئويه ويبقى
في كتله صلبه ايا كان حتى لو حديد لان
الحديد ينصهر عند قويه
الحديث
اوكي تمام
ههه
انت الان شرحته ان هو مسؤول عن الجاذبيه
وامور مهمه كثير يعني طيب الان لما ينعكس
الموضوع اشرح يصير
ما هو انا بما انه مسؤول عن الجاذبيه وهو
قتل حديديه
والسائل او الصهير المحيط بيه هذا الصهير
في حركه دائمه وبالتالي بيتولد تيار
كهربائي وبتولد مجال مغناطيسي هنا في
النقطه انا هاجي لحضرتك ما الفائده اييي
هذا هذا الدوران بيجعل الكتله الحديديه
مغناطيس قوي جدا بيجذب الحديد اللي بيتكون
اليه وبالتالي بينمو ويكون المغناطيس
الكره الارضيه هنا ال- ال- احنا درسنا
الكلام ده عرفناه ازاي ما فيش طريقه لان
ده على عمق 5,000 كيلو متر ما نقدرش
وبعدين في وسط 7000 درجه مئويه فازاي
المعلومات جاءت جبناها عن طريق الزلازل
اللي بتحصل على سطح الارض بين القصه في
الوجه الاخر من الكره الارضيه
وبالتالي
الصخور
فاحنا في همم الصخور اللي على الحواف اللي
هي لا يمر بها الموجات
بنجد ان السرعات ثابته لكن لما الموجات
تمر بمركز الارض لان ان السرعه مختلفه هذا
معناه ان في شيء في في مركز الكره الارضيه
هذا معناه ان في دوران البحث بقى هنا بقى
الجديد في البحث انه بيقول ان ان احنا
شوفنا ان السرعه ان السرعه ثابته وبالتالي
ده معناه ان هل الكتله توقفت عن الدوران
لكن في همم الاحتمال الاكبر وهو ان هذه
الكتله بتدور مع الارض بنفس سرعه دوران
الارض هذا معناه انها تعتبر ثابته بالنسبه
للارض هذا شيء احنا بنلمسه بالدوران القمر
حوالين الارض طالما
يعني لا تضيعني انا انسانه يعني معلومات
على جده
ده انا معلوماتي علاج جدا جدا
هيلف او هيتغير انتم اكتشفته ايش بيعمل
واكتشفته ايش اللي بيغير حركاته وان هو
بيدور وبينعكس الان اللي انعكاس ده خطر
لم يثبت انه هينعكس
الثابت دلوقتي في البحث اللي بيقول ان
السرعه خلال ال 10 سنوات الاخيره ما
تغيرتش لم تتغير معناه وكان هذه الكتله
الكره الحديديه كانها ثابته لكن هي لا هي
في الحقيقه هي متحركه بنفس سرعه الكره
الارضيه فبالنسبه للاشعه اللي بتمر او
الموجات الزلزاليه بتمر بنفس المكان فاذا
ده بيؤكد ما كنا نعلمه قبل كده فقالوا فيه
دوره دوره في 35 سنه هذه الكره
بتدور بسرعه اكبر قليله من سرعه الارض ثم
تقل تدريجيا الى ان تتساوى في فتره مع
شجره الارض ثم بعد كده تقل عن سرعه الارض
هذه الدوره مدتها 70 سنه احنا دلوقت في
منتصف هذه الدوره معنى ذلك ان هذه الكتله
بتدور حاليا بنفس سرعه الارض وهذا يؤكد
طالما انه بنفس السرعه يبقى
همم
الزمن معناها ان ما فيش تغير في السرعات
حاليا المقاسه بوابالتالي يعني اللي بيخلي
البعض انها خلاص توقفت لا هي لم تتوقف ولن
تدور في الاتجاه المعاكس لان ده هيبقى
مخالف للكره الارضيه هذه الكتله هي
المسؤوله عن الجاذبيه مسؤوله عن اشياء
كثيره على سطح الارض منها بعض الموجات
البحريه مسؤوله عن بعد ممكن همم ده يفسر
والحقيقه ده عامل من ضمن العوامل الكثيره
اللي ممكن نقول انها ممكن تؤثر في
التغيرات المناخيه ولذلك احنا بنشوف في
بعض الموجات في سنوات تكون حاره في سنوات
تكون درجه الحراره فيها منخفضه في سنوات
يكون فيها جفاف شديد في سنوات اخرى
ان ان اللب ده يكون له تاثير على ما يحدث
على سطح الارض لكن ما يحدث الان ليس بجديد
على الكره الارضيه ولكن الجديد بالنسبه
لنا احنا معلوماتنا احنا احنا
بنزيد من معلوماتنا لانها لب الكوره
الارضيه على عمق 5000 كيلو وما فيش وسيله
ما فيش رحله تنزل تحت الارض ولا هذه
الصخور انها تطلع على سطح الارض البراكين
بتطلع من ال 100 كيلو الاولى واحنا عندنا
نصف الكره الارضيه اكثر من 6,000 و300
كيلو متر فبالتالي هذا الجزء واحنا كمان
عرفنا ل- اا المكون بتاع ان هو حديد ونيكل
منين لان قلنا الجاذبيه في هذا الجزء
بتبقى اكبر طيب والتكوين التركيب
الكيميائي والصخري عرفناه من النيازك اللي
بتنزل على سطح الارض لانها بتكون اقرب ما
يكون يعني احنا حتى عرفنا انه حديث اوكي
اللي بيصير واللي مش بيصير هذه الحركه
والسرعه والكلام هذا كله طيب الان الدراسه
هذه لمن طلعت ليش صارت حاله الفزع هذه
والناس قالوا انه العالم هينتهي والناس
قالوا انه الشمس راح تطلع من
غرب ما انه الارض هينعكس ليش صار هذا
الكلام
هذا كلام في مبالغه شديده ولا يعني حتى
البحث نفسه لم يحذر من مخاطر ولكن كل ما
بنوصل لمعلومه بيظهر لنا عشرات الاسئله
الاخرى هنا الكتله الحديديه ما هو شكل
الكتله الحديديه هل هي مكونه هل هي
بيضاويه هل همم لان الكره الارضيه نفسها
بيضاويه فبالتالي ايه شكل هذا الجزء
وكيفيه الدوران اسئله كثيره ويمكن البحث
خرج في النهايه في التوصيات الاخيره ان
مطلوب مزيد من الابحاث لمعرفه معلومات
اكثر عن هذا الجزء الهام بالنسبه للكره
الارضيه طيب انا تمنياتي لكم بالتوفيق في
هذه همم ايوه والله دي من البدايه اللي
باستناها انا يا دكتور والله اه دي النقطه
المهمه فعلا اه بالضبط يا دكتور طيب المهم
استمروا في الابحاث وان شاء الله ما يصير
اي خطر لا علينا ولا على الكره الارضيه
ويمشي حالنا انا حتى
يعني من الفزع اللي عندي بس مش عارفه اجلس
على الكرسي على ام بشكرك حلا وجودك معانا
كان معنا من القاهره استاذ الجيولوجيا
دكتور عباس الشراقي شكرا لك